[Applause]
you see what
what all these uh fast food players have
done they're like we like to reduce the
amount of like
person to person contact because of
corona so why don't you just order your
[ __ ] on these screens oh is that why
yeah you haven't been setting this [ __ ]
up for the last [ __ ] yeah this is the
perfect opportunity to get you used to
it
mm-hmm remember how long it took for us
to get used to the [ __ ]
thing at the grocery store in cbs or
yeah do it yourself i hate that [ __ ]
actually took years
but if we had to do it and we were like
oh this makes us safer then you just get
used to it you know you're not mentally
fighting it you're like no this protects
us yeah you're right
have you guys ever stole from those
machines we should we should all
i don't know why what's in me it crossed
my mind every single time i've never
done it
and i won't do it i don't know why
billboard why do i have this like
i know it's okay it's bad to steal but
it's almost like i feel like oh
i'm really [ __ ] somebody over if i
steal this
piece of chewing gum like for some
reason i don't know what it is
yeah what did they brainwash us to
that's a good point maybe it's like it's
so
obvious that you're like oh something's
up here yeah i think you're more likely
to get caught at those things one
because you're on camera
yeah so they have a camera in the thing
like you if you have a bunch of [ __ ]
like oh boop this one didn't get you you
could take a pack of gum probably
everything yeah
wait actually packing them might even be
difficult unless you put in your pocket
so there is the weight situation it's
not that accurate is it not
not really like it can sense changes and
[ __ ] like that but
if you put half your bags down and be
like yo i can't fit any more stuff here
so it's like they have to just override
the [ __ ]
that makes sense yeah it is interesting
and it could be that it could just be
like
it's too obvious this seems like a trap
i'm not going to do it yeah
i don't feel i don't want to steal i
feel like i'm too old et cetera but like
mentally i would feel more satisfied
stealing from them i
don't steal i do
consume within the store and not pay and
i feel completely okay with it
i've done this [ __ ] a lot on accident
and on purpose
stealing it's not stealing look at those
two minorities non-criminals you write
about this [ __ ]
you guys y'all don't know how to steal
y'all stealing run out we eat it in the
store and walk out yeah
well i've done it on accident where i
normally will just go through the store
and i'll be like eating [ __ ]
keep going and then i'll [ __ ] told you
you got a bullet
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll go
through and i'll be eating [ __ ] and then
i go to the checkout lady and then i'll
have her swipe
i'll have her scan the trash that's what
you're supposed to do
but i go hey i ate all these oreos can
you scan it and then
and then she'll scan the garbage and
throw it away and then and then and
that's it yes
don't pay for it sometimes but then
other times i forget and then sometimes
it'll just be in the car
see i don't forget and i don't do it
leaving the place without paying you do
leave the place back
i actually leave the place without it
it's in your belly it's in your tummy
i trust that that's actually not true
it's in your tummy it's not in my tummy
and your small intestines
it's maybe it's in my stomach i don't
know if i trust your gut anymore yeah
you're
not trustworthy yo dishonest ass guts
y'all are really active that's the
dishonest gut you got damn
yo do we let him have it yeah
you